solo faltan 100 días para que la capital
china inaugure las olimpiadas de
invierno de 2022 el mayor desafío la
pandemia el gigante asiático lucha
contra un rebrote de kobe 19 y los
organizadores se preparan
hemos decidido implementar sistemas
estrictos de grupos burbuja para todo el
personal es una de las principales
medidas de prevención de la epidemia
para asegurar que el juego se darán en
total seguridad las reglas se aplicarán
a todos los deportistas personal y
voluntarios quienes serán aislados
estrictamente de la población al ver
show línea
en hyde además de las burbujas cerradas
los organizadores también ponen un
testeo riguroso y una estricta política
de vacunación para evitar los 21 días de
cuarentena los que no cumplan con las
regulaciones se enfrentarán a severas
consecuencias incluida la expulsión
y como en los juegos olímpicos de tokio
no se permitirán espectadores
internacionales ya que las fronteras
siguen cerradas
aunque china mantiene una política de
'tolerancia cero' para eliminar el virus
desde que emergió en 2019 el lunes
millones de personas entraron en
cuarentena locales debido a un aumento
de las infecciones
la comisión nacional de salud registró
50 casos de contagios locales en varias
regiones la cifra diaria más alta desde
que el brote empezó a mediados de
octubre
los juegos olímpicos de invierno de
beijing deben empezar el 4 de febrero